logra una victoria en un día clave
cuando él y su gobierno se enfrentaban a
dos mociones de censura aquí en la
asamblea nacional una de ellas la que
más probabilidades tenía de pasar tan
Solamente le faltaron nueve votos para
hacer aprobada mientras que la segunda
moción esa vez presentada por la
reagrupación nacional el partido de
extrema derechas tan solo obtuvo 94
votos de los 287 necesarios a pesar de
que puede verse esto como una victoria
Lo cierto es que Manuel y su gobierno
salen bastante debilitados justamente
cuando su nivel de popularidad está en
lo más abajo pero sobre todo cuando la
oposición está pidiendo la cabeza de
Elizabeth piden simplemente su renuncia
y dicen además que ante los franceses
este gobierno está muerto ahora es
posible que Emmanuel maco haga cambios a
su gabinete en los próximos días más
teniendo en cuenta todo lo que negoció
con los republicanos el partido de
derecha para que este partido votara a
favor de la Reforma pensional
especialmente en el senado esta reforma
que con este resultado de las mociones
de censura pues termina siendo
plenamente adoptada aquí en la asamblea
nacional y ahora pasa a ser estudiada
por el consejo constitucional mientras
que por su parte la oposición de
izquierda está pidiendo un referendo de
iniciativa popular para someter al voto
de los ciudadanos franceses está reforma